salut à tous pour ce nouveau numéro je
vous emmène à la découverte de liste
rouge cette entreprise taille des
chemises sur mesure pour une clientèle
très sélect mais avant de découvrir l'
usine qui se trouve à condé sur noireau
petit détour par la boutique parisienne
c'est normand c'est parti situé rue
saint-honoré à quelques encablures de
l'elysée ce magasin est la vitrine de
liste rouge
mais l'histoire de l'entreprise est
ancrée ailleurs en normandie à condé sur
noireau depuis 1938 un savoir faire
unique se transmet de petites mains en
petites mains dominé toutes les
informations des clients se trouvent sur
cette fiche
oui donc à partir du monde commandes et
de la fiche on à la référence des tissus
la forme des cols des poignets ça
commence par la déco prochainement par
la découpe donc avec un patron de base
auquel on rajoute des rectifications qui
nous sont demandés d'accord vous avez
combien de référence de tissu
entre deux et trois mille références et
tout le sort de toutes sortes de tissus
principalement du coton et cachemire de
la soie tout ce que sont que les ans
qu'ils ôtent voilà des produits haut de
gamme
facturée en moyenne entre 300 et 800
euros
le col les poignées chaque détail de la
chemise est choisie par le client
toutes les fantaisies sont acceptés
c'est cette chemise vont bientôt
s'envoler pour la chine
coût de l'opération 7500 euros non c'est
une broderie entièrement à la main voilà
vous avez de nos sociétés avec un soleil
de deux couleurs en rosace autour d'une
centrale personnes vous le ferai même
dans des grandes maisons si vous le
demandez on vous le ferai pas ou
peut-être en machine
c'est tout à la main une plus value
réalisée par kelly la brodeuse de la
maison des initiales ou des dessins
signe distinctif du haut de gamme très
apprécié par cette clientèle en cinq
minutes des leds simple
c'est là qu'il ya plusieurs lettres
scheer est un bon quart d'heure à une
demi heure
bonjour jean les compagnies des bons
jouait alors depuis la petite boutique à
flers en 1938 la maison a
considérablement évolué oui
effectivement là beaucoup évolué et on
est parti d'un produit qui était un
produit demi-mesure industriel qu'on a
stoppé dans les années 80 pour le
transformer en véritables produits sur
mesure jusque dans les moindres détails
aujourd'hui vous allez sur le haut de
gamme ou et on est vraiment positionné
sur le haut de gamme ou travers des
matières par exemple
une fiv rossi island qu'une fibre coton
tout à fait exceptionnel cultivé dans
les caraïbes de façon manuelle qui nous
produit un fils un peu exceptionnel et
donc
également un tissu tout à fait tout à
fait particulier ces dernières années
liste rouge est devenu un concurrent
direct d'hermès ou de la maison charvet
une montée en gamme de garanties par le
travail exceptionnel de ces couturières
rémunérer un peu plus que le salaire
minimum
vous réfléchissez au décalage qu'il ya
entre le prix de la chemise et le
salaire des ouvrières oui ça nous arrive
quand même d'y penser
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire dit qu'on
aurait bien aimé gagner un peu plus cher
pour quand même pour le produit
vous l'avez compris la vraie richesse de
l'entreprise s'appelle coralie rowland
ou thérèse qui part après 29 ans de
maison c'est ça la même il me reste à
veut dire à très bientôt pour un
prochain ces normes